es ist furchtbar traurig bis dahin
kommen konnte es ist doch ein
wunderbarer beruf das ist der einzige
beruf die nicht gelernt habe und ich
finde es nach wie vor ist ein handwerk
das viel viel freude macht und es hat
was mit dienstleistungen zu tun und
dienstleistungen heißt dienen und
leisten und würde das gerne macht dem
gefällt dass in der schweiz arbeiten
doch 200.000 menschen als banker ich
kann kein mensch überzeugen dass 200.000
menschen als abzocker oder ganoven sein
sollten das ist wirklich schade
wirklich tragisch dass es dahin gekommen
ist buch kartfahren holt ist top banker
in zürich seit jahren bewegte sich in
den chefetagen großer schweizer banken
als chef des investment managements bei
julius bär verwaltet er millionen
vermögen der superreichen uganda hier
ist burkhard varnholt gründer und
betreiber eines dorfes für waisenkinder
hier ist der entwicklungshilfe
hoffnungsträger für kinder mit einer
schrecklichen vergangenheit
wie bringt er die welt der verlierer mit
der welt der gewinner unter einen jungen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
an der mur gartenstraße 1 mitten im
zürcher bankenzentrum beschäftigt sich
burkhardt fahren holt mit den wünschen
seiner reichen kundschaft als chef
verantwortet er wie die bank das geld
anlegt in der branche gilt vahrenholt
als vertreter des nachhaltigen bankings
nachhaltiges banking das heißt das geld
der kunden verantwortungsbewusst in
nachhaltige unternehmen zu investieren
die frage stellt sich hat das
unternehmen einen plan wie es damit
langfristig umgehen will wie es das was
es nimmt auch wieder zurückgibt und es
muss nicht in der gleichen form zwingend
zurückgegeben werden aber es muss so
zurückgegeben werden dass das
unternehmen durch seine tätigkeit nicht
an irgendeinem tag in der zukunft von
der gesellschaft so angeschaut wird dass
man sich sagt mit diesem unternehmen
wollen und können wir nicht mehr
arbeiten was passiert unternehmen die zu
schlechter zu schlecht ihrer die risiken
ihrer anlagen beaufsichtigen die dann
unfälle generieren et cetera also nicht
der schnelle gewinn sondern
nachhaltigkeit soll sein handeln
bestimmen
wie kann einer der so spricht wie
burkhard varnholt trotzdem in eine
solche spitzenposition kommen dies gelte
wo sie dauernd matthias sicherlich zum
beispiel ich habe es aus irgendwelchen
quellen kommt die man wo man wo man sagt
das soll es nicht geben das darf es
nicht geben solche situationen habe ich
selbstverständlich schon erlebt und da
brauchen sie an einer uni name natürlich
das sind situationen gewesen wo
eigentlich schon in den ersten drei
minuten klar war dass hier keine
geschäftsbeziehung entstehen würde
meistens spürt man sehr rasch dann führt
man das gespräch noch zu ende und nicht
immer nicht immer aber das ist auch ein
teil der erfahrung
spürt man dass rasch obmann haupt sich
aus dem gespräch in der
geschäftsbeziehung ergeben kann oder
nicht
ein top winkel der aus der reihe tanzt
auf jeden fall unüblich für einen
menschen seiner kategorie dass er meinen
kameramann und mich zu sich mit nach
hause nimmt
burkhard varnholt scheint keine
berührungsängste zu haben
[Musik]
das ist seine frau salomé ja hier wohne
ich mit meiner familie meine frau ist
die architekten die die wohnung für uns
vor 14 jahren entworfen hat und heute
sind wir glücklich mit den kindern und
den haustieren die dazu gehören die
bänke wechselt jetzt nicht nur das tun
sondern auch die welt er macht sich auf
nach uganda zu seinem kinderdorf kids
auf afrika-reise zufälle im leben
manchmal so geht vor zwölf jahren hatte
ich im bett gedreht bekommen wir sogar
aus dem bett brief hat sich über
verschiedene zufälle einer brief
bekanntschaft deine freundschaft ergeben
und später schließlich das kinderdorf
und das sehen wir dann ja in den ersten
tagen 15 stunden später ankunft in
entdeckt burkhard varnholt wird von kate
olsen abgeholt er ist leiter des
waisenhauses
wir sind in einem der ärmsten länder der
welt die überwiegende mehrheit der
einwohner muss mit einem dollar pro tag
auskommen
die menschen lebten in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten immer wieder unter
bürgerkriegen und despoten wie dem
geisteskranken idi amin
[Musik]
da wo die straße aufhört noch ein paar
hundert meter weiter ist unser ziel
[Musik]
direkt am victoriasee hat burkhard
varnholt ein weisendorf und eine schule
gebaut
der schuldirektor empfängt den hohen
gast aus der schweiz und begleitet ihn
auf seiner begrüßungsrunde
die weißen kinder nennen den schweizer
top banker einfach ampel buchert
[Musik]
dieses gebäude war schon seit den 70er
jahren hier so den 70er jahren gebaut
und zwar ursprünglich als fisch factory
angelegt wir sind hier direkt am see und
man sieht hier diese ursprünglich diese
paprika also nicht fabrikation sondern
ich weiß auch nicht viele tierhalter
oder wie man das nennt das war damals
ein geschäft und wir haben es jetzt
eigentlich nur um genutzt und
klassenzimmer da rein gemacht und das
gebäude ist stabil gebaut so gute
qualität und das ist eigentlich schön so
was lässt man natürlich bestehen wenn
man kann
und jetzt gehen wir hier einen
provisorium das war ursprünglich mal als
ziegenstall genutzt deswegen ist es
wenigstens etwas wo immer viel luft ist
und das nutzen wir so lange wir das
provisorium im augenblick gut brauchen
nebst den 100 kindern aus dem weisendorf
nimmt die schule auch auswärtige aus den
umliegenden dörfern auf burkhard
varnholt begrüßt sie alle und schaut in
jedes klassenzimmer
es fällt mir auf wie vorsichtig er sich
den schülern ehrt ich spüre der forscher
das ist vielleicht nur bei der begrüßung
so wenn man sich sieht da war ich fühle
mich überhaupt nicht im gegenteil ich
fühle mich zu hause mit den menschen die
hier im dorf sind ich bin ich zu hause
wenn ich die kinder sehe die aus dem
kinderdorf machen
aber es ist vielleicht eine andere
tonalität als als bei uns bei uns ist
doch manchmal das leben lauter und
bunter und teams die tonalität manchmal
etwas
mehr respekt ausgerechnet besucher auch
beim küchenpersonal das für die schüler
das mittagessen zubereitet
die aufmerksamkeit des hilfswerks
gründers gilt weniger dem essen denn
einem baby das am schreien ist
er erkundigt sich nach der mutter und
nach dem alter des kindes ein top banker
in uganda hier manager der auch
schreiende babys
[Musik]
burkhard varnholt ist wieder angekommen
in der welt der bedürftigen willkommen
auch seine finanzielle kraft wie viel in
das dorf kostet will er öffentlich
nichts sagen da ist er ganz banker nur
es sei mehr als er sich zu beginn vor
zehn jahren vorgestellt habe
[Musik]
die rundumbetreuung der 100 waisenkinder
ist personalintensiv lehrer gärtner
pflegemittel köchinnen der regelmäßige
und persönliche kontakt mit ihnen sei
wichtig sagt burkhard varnholt alle zwei
monate bin ich hier und ziehe den
fortschritt der nicht möglich wäre ohne
eure guten hände und guten herzen
wir sind auf diesem kurs seit vielen
jahren so wie es eine gute familie sein
sollte
es ist der geist des dazu gehören der
diesen ort zu einem zuhause für viele
macht macht weiter mit einer guten
arbeit
gott segne euch eure familien und euer
land
dann sind die angestellten an der reihe
und es passiert das was keiner erwartet
hätte
ein angestellter ergreift das wort und
beklagt sich beim banker über den lohn
auch im namen seiner kollegen er
verdiene 250 im monat
das sei nicht fair das sei zu wenig um
seine familie zu ernähren
burkhard varnholt entgegnet das thema
komme immer wieder aber man müsse es
auch immer wieder offen und konstruktiv
angehen nur man könne nicht mehr
ausgeben als man habe er wisse aber aus
vergleichen das kids of africa ein gut
bezahlen der arbeitgeber sei und für
jeden angestellten auch altersvorsorge
und steuern begleiche und so bleibt ihre
lohnforderung erfolglos im ugandischen
weisendorf des schweizer bankers ist der
rasen geschnitten und die hecke gepflegt
ich bekomme den eindruck dass burkhard
varnholt hier ein kleines paradies für
die 100 kinder gebaut hat
in jedem dieser häuser leben zehn kinder
mit einer pflegemutter mutter jocelyn
ist seit beginn dabei
sie kocht putzt wäscht sie umsorgt ihre
zehn kinder und gibt ihnen liebe tag und
nacht
[Musik]
die idylle lässt fast vergessen welch
schreckliches schicksal dieser kinder
haben
eines wurde am straßenrand gefunden in
zeitungen eingewickelt es war drei tage
alt ein anderes wurde von seiner mutter
fast zu tode gewürgt bevor es die
gehörten retteten
[Musik]
die geschichte dieses jungen buben ging
pflegemutter jocelyn besonders nahe
sie begleitet ihn jetzt schon seit
jahren sein vater und seine stiefmutter
wollten ihn verhungern lassen
sie versteckten ihn unter dem bett als
die nachbarn auf wild dass er nicht mehr
draußen war schalteten sie die polizei
ein
diese fand den jungen fast tot er war
nur noch ein skelett
dann kam mir zuerst ins spital für
monate er musste sich ja wieder erholen
dann brachte ihn die behörde hierher
von da an hat er sich stetig zu einem
gesund aussehenden jungen entwickelt
[Musik]
schicksale in einem land wo die menschen
in bitterer armut leben
armut auch als folge unseres reichtums
[Musik]
liegen auf schweizer banken nicht gelder
von afrikanischen potentaten
schwarzgelder unversteuerte milliarden
gewinne von rohstofffirmen die sich die
reichtümer dieses kontinentes zunutze
machen
[Musik]
go kart fahren holt ist ein top
vertreter der schweizer bankenwelt
einerseits auf der anderen seite kommt
er hierher und tut gutes wie bringt
diese gegensätze zusammen ist aus
engagement positive macht eine abdeckte
eine kompensation nach was für eine
schreckliche vorstellung nein ich bin
zum einen auch protestant und ich denke
dass der gesamte gedanke des atlasses
wie es ihn im mittelalter war
logischerweise eine verirrung war die
nirgendwohin führen konnte und das hat
ja noch ziemlich jeder gewusst
oder um es anders zu sagen was ich hier
mache war zu keinem zeitpunkt ausdruck
eines schlechten gewissens burkhard
varnholt will sich gegen eine
pauschalverurteilung der bankenwelt
gegen die sippenhaft verantwortung lässt
sich nicht teilen das gilt im positiven
wie im negativen
verantwortung muss dafür muss man gerade
stehen und die vielen vielen tausend
kollegen und kolleginnen von mir die
auch in banken arbeiten die noch nie in
ihrem leben und das geht mir genau
gleich einen solchen afrikanischen
potentaten gesehen haben oder ein konto
eines solchen potentaten gesehen haben
sondern genauso wie sie auch darüber aus
den medien etwas lesen sie haben damit
nichts zu tun
einfach nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein bisschen geht es mir wie diesen
läufern her
ich kämpfe und mühe mich ab will den top
banker packen und erfassen doch er ist
immer etwas schneller entgleitet und
enteilt mir zweifellos ist sein
persönliches engagement echtgeld einfach
irgendwohin schicken liegt ihm fern
deshalb hat er sein eigenes hilfswerk
aufgebaut
vielleicht bei einer motivation auch
dass man wirklich kontrolle hyper das
hat was hier passiert ich weiß jede
schraube die hier investiert wird wie
das funktioniert wie das abgerechnet
wird und wenn ich an eines glaube in der
entwicklungshilfe was funktioniert dann
sind es diese grass roots ansätze weil
die den großen vorteil haben dass sie
klein kontrolliert und im idealfall dann
auch langfristig mit herzblut
durchgeführt werden können
zum abschluss seines zweitägigen
besuches wird noch richtig gefeiert
zehn kinder haben im letzten monat
geburtstag gehabt
[Applaus]
kinder die ohne den wohltäter aus der
schweiz vielleicht nicht mehr am leben
wären zurück in der schweiz zu hause bei
seiner familie eine frage liegt mir
schon lange auf der zunge
woher kommt seine motivation zum teilen
burkhard varnholt beantwortet auch diese
frage auf seine weise es geht also auch
an gut und wenn man dann trotzdem noch
kahlen kann dann ist es umso besser und
es sich ja so dass nicht nur minimal bis
kann so mehr biss zu
richtig sei dass man hier nach
bitterfeld das man schlagen es gibt die
einen top banker und seine ehefrau mit
einer sozialen verantwortung
[Musik]